good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight you can be forgiven if
the events of the last month caught you
by surprise you didn't expect them you'd
become used to dismissing the American
left out of hand as a joke because they
are since the day Donald Trump was
inaugurated Democratic Party has been
helplessly disorganized and totally
ineffective as a political party they
wasted years chasing invisible Russian
agents and then making weird and
unintelligible sounds about something
called Ukraine it's still not clear what
they meant by that their entire
political strategy was bizarre and in
the end it was counterproductive and
hurt them with voters they went down in
the polls
only buffoons do that in politics these
people couldn't organize your kids
birthday party they didn't make their
beds this morning and yet suddenly out
of nowhere they roared back and took
over the country they did it in less
time than it takes most people to go on
spring vacation what happened
how'd they do that well it's simple
nobody stopped them
there was no opposition to their power
grab the other side surrendered on day
one without a fight the rest of us
watched all of this with our jaws
hanging open in shock was the opposite
of what we expected millions people
regularly vote for the Republican Party
precisely because they would like
someone to protect this country from the
crazed ideologues who seek to destroy it
there are many of them watching them on
television now there's not really
another reason to vote Republican unless
you have any one of those rare people
who wants more pointless Foreign Wars
and enjoys sucking up to banks most
people don't you vote for Republicans to
protect you from this but when the
moment of crisis came Republicans ran
away major American cities were leading
and burned on television citizens were
beaten and murdered works of public art
were destroyed by the score America's
history those shared experiences that
bind us together as a nation was
plundered and completely rewritten by
illiterate vandals everywhere as they
watched Americans were afraid afraid not
simply for their safety but afraid for
their jobs their reputations are afraid
for their families many Americans were
fired up
roughly in the middle of a severe
recession doomed to ruin for nothing for
saying the wrong thing looking the wrong
way liking the wrong tweet that happened
it's happening now some of the accused
were so terrified they denounced their
own families wife brother daughter in
the end they were destroyed anyway
because that's what happens in purchase
you're destroyed anyway
most Americans assume they would never
live to see a moment like this but they
have it's still going on and the
question that hangs in the air is where
are our protectors at the height of the
riots the president of the Heritage
Foundation that's the nation's single
largest conservative think-tank it has
consumed billions of donor dollars the
president of Heritage wrote an op-ed
accusing America of being irredeemably
racist her name is K Col James you
probably have sent her money as America
burned K coal James president of the
Heritage Foundation piled on and she
wasn't alone in that so many on the
right did exactly the same thing
meanwhile they did nothing they didn't
lift a finger to help the people they
had promised they had pledged to protect
their voters and their donors instead
they did everything possible to
accommodate the demands of the people
tormenting them the rioters and the
people who backed the rioters
congressional Republicans decided to
make reining in law enforcement their
top legislative priority they blame to
the cops they didn't blame the rioters
they blamed the cops then Republicans
bragged about springing more criminals
from jail the last thing we needed in
the state of Iowa the Republican
governor announced that she was giving
felons the vote by executive order not
even waiting for the election just doing
it signing it meanwhile almost
everywhere ordinary Americans came under
attack for the color of their skin acts
of actual races and where people were
being hurt for their race something they
can't control something they were born
with and yet no Republicans rose to
defend them Republicans refused even to
defend the principle of equality under
the law the foundation of this country
the most important thing we have not
defendant
really in the end the only people who
gained anything in the revolution were
the ones waging in our leaders very much
including our Republican leader
shamefully we're focused on meeting
their demands so what should we conclude
from what we just saw the message
unfortunately could not be clearer
voting is for fools you vote you put
these people into office with your votes
and in return they patronize you and
when it matters they abandon you they
have contempt for you you know they do
you can smell it it's obvious voting
doesn't work but when you riot and you
burn things and you hurt people you get
a very different response when you do
those things are leaders snap to
attention they tiptoe around your
feelings as Republicans are they give
you what you want as Republicans are
rioting works
that's the message they're sending think
about that it's the most dangerous
possible message you can send because it
guarantees more violence you've got to
wonder how all of this would have played
out if Barack Obama was still president
let's say it was the summer of 2011
right before obama's reelection campaign
started in earnest imagine if at that
politically critical moment violent mobs
of mitt romney supporters began leading
and burning major American cities
screaming racist slogans as they did it
hard to imagine but try imagine if the
Romney mob then defaced and tore down
statues of Martin Luther King in public
parks imagine if every street sign in
America identifying a Martin Luther King
Boulevard was suddenly lipped to the
ground and defaced with graffiti most
Americans would find that appalling and
disgusting we certainly would but let's
say the mob kept doing it because nobody
stopped them imagine of the people who
plan to vote for Barack Obama in the
fall knew they couldn't admit that in
public if citizens wearing Obama hats
were physically assaulted punched in the
face thrown to the sidewalk and kicked
imagine if anyone who spoke out against
the mobs or showed support for Obama's
campaign was censored or deep platformed
by tech monopolies that operated at the
pleasure of federal regulators imagine
if those same monopolies censored
President Obama himself so ask yourself
sincerely if all of that happened
how do you think Barack Obama would have
responded like tweeting angry things by
effectively apologizing to the mob
meeting their demands for quote reform
and then declaring a new national
holiday at their request that probably
not it's hard to imagine Barack Obama
doing that it's hard to imagine him
complaining that his President of the
United States he didn't have the power
to stop political violence or preserve
the integrity of an election or protect
free speech or public art or the
nation's history itself no that would
not happen instead within about 10
minutes you would see the Obama Justice
Department indict every single person
involved on federal conspiracy and civil
rights charges you would watch his SEAL
Team six reclaimed downtown Seattle
you'd see airborne units drop from the
sky into Atlanta Minneapolis and
Portland you would see whatever it took
to stop the chaos that revolution would
not last long say what you will about
Barack Obama and we do but he never
doubted he had the constitutional
authority to act and he did act Obama
knew a threat when he saw one our
Republican leaders don't believe they
have the authority they don't believe
they're legitimate they don't see the
threat they don't want to see the threat
because they know they can't face the
mob they know they're too weak and so
they offer trinkets that hope the mob
will go away but it won't mobs can't be
sated we thought Republicans understood
that that's why we supported them but
crisis has revealed the truth now we
know who they are it could not be
clearer and now it's time to find new
leaders